the world we live in contains greater
challenges and greater opportunities
than at any time in human history while
the global financial crisis is impacting
citizens and families around the world
it's also prompting governments
companies and leaders to look for fresh
solutions this year at the world
economic forum in davos switzerland
leading thinkers from all walks of life
will come together to examine solutions
to the problems we face and they want
you to be part of the discussion and
have the chance to attend davos yourself
all expenses paid we just have to keep
the hope alive the theme for this year's
forum is shaping the post-crisis world
hello youtube hello youtube my name is
Dominic War II and I'm head of
environmental initiatives of the World
Economic Forum hello youtube I Maria
Bartiromo from CNBC I'm Christiane
Amanpour and I'm going to be at the
world economic forum in davos
switzerland january 29 the leaders in
davos will be debating key issues
relating to the economy the environment
politics and ethics you can join that
debate by voting on four basic questions
posted on youtube com / Davos and you
can go further upload a video with your
answer to one or all of these questions
the best video overall will get to join
the most influential people in the world
at Davos all-expenses-paid the developed
world needs to severely curb our
consumption of materials and energy that
runs on their own individual perspective
of how they see things and how they see
the world is very personal to me it's
not just political it's not just public
I see what's happening versus so submit
your video today the deadline is 20
january 2009
engage debate at 10
on the most pressing questions at Davos
at youtube.com slash Davos